I was in a town before called um Langan
Village it was called and basically
there was a young lad and he looked
awful similar to me I thought I was
fighting in the mirror right come
outside the nightclub I was like do I
know you from somewhere and he goes do I
know you do you know and he had he had a
Celtic jersey on but he had he had the
green and yellow one right and I was I
was about to throw a punch and then he
he looked at me in the eyes and I go do
I he goes am I your father I said to him
and he goes to me am I your son and we
just hugged it out turns out that no
relation at all I just headbutted him
and he got T away but you know it goes
to show you people are out there you
could know
them goes to show